and now as we're in the throes of
election season it is time for another
installment of voter voices this
incredibly important classic segment
that we've only actually done one other
time this is what we hear from a niche
group of voters who could sway this very
close election tonight's group is
furries the Facebook page furries for
Trump is titillating voters with its
sexy rabbit drawings just ruined Space
Jam for me the hashtag furries for
Hillary has been used a whopping five
times so here to give us a perspective
of an undecided furry is Connor coop aka
dream horse sweet nipple
thank you thank you everyone thank you
for having me Chris
now we furries may seem a little out
there but we're just like you we are
lawyers we are teachers we're doctors
I'm an unlicensed gynecologist for
instance we're normal Americans who just
happened to derive sexual gratification
cranking it too crude sketches of
Raccoon people with arm length dolls now
first of all you're naturally not very
furry do not velour shame me okay I am
sorry cutter I'm very sorry
oh please call me a dream or sweet
nipple when I'm in my true skin all
right mr. sweet nipple actually sorry it
is actually dr. sweet nib okay I didn't
spend six years getting my nipples
sweetened in medical school to be called
mr. on a basic-cable program doctor dr.
sweet nipple okay okay so politically
where are you right now why are you
undecided I get a little worked up oh
boy am i presenting to the right yeah
you're presenting that's right you're
presenting very well and it's something
about you squatting makes it creepier
hold this would be a relatively safe
space tom you told me at convention this
was gonna be a safe space what once your
hair it's fair game you're in the arena
paranoid speaking of game
part of me is drawn to trump because of
his tax policy I would love to be able
to write off my dry cleaning expenses
every year I do spend a lot of money on
dry cleaning like how much like forty
five to fifty thousand why i jizz in
this thing all the time is oh I see okay
well on the other hand though I am I am
drawn to Hillary's maternity leave
policy okay because I'm a bad unicorn
and needs to be spanked by his mommy
well I don't think that's I don't think
that's what the plant is actually setup
for actually if you go through her
website oh come on you just knocked over
the ashes of Lucille Ball we keep that
for good luck this was the I Love Lucy
stage and Mary granted it was probably a
bad idea to keep it there next year
rainbow
all right you know what thank you for
being here you did a good job do you
want to come get come get a nap yes
please welcome Apple palm I will bite
you okay all right good good good
that's doctor dream sweet nipple
I'm glad we give people a voice on this
show for a unicorn that was actually
kind of average size better watch
yourself Voldemort sucked his to stay
alive it was he's Mormon he's more of a
duo corn you're right